let's jump into the first story
in that regard here we go let's get into
the news we got this from timcast.com
human remains of missing paddle boarder
found in pond at Obama's Martha's
Vineyard estate
the man has been described as a black 43
year old but identity has not been made
public now at the time of uh this uh
writing we did not know now we know that
it was Obama's chef
Obama's Chef was paddle boarding this is
uh Dom lukray says dead body found at
Obama's Martha's Martha's Vineyard
estate in search for a black 43 year old
male paddle boarder who drowned in the
pond attached to the estate 9-1-1 call
was made from ex-president's 12 million
dollar property night last night sorry
and uh shortly before 10 a.m the body of
the missing paddle boarder was recovered
from Edgar Town Great Pond by
Massachusetts State Police diverse MSP
underwater Recovery Unit made the
recovery after the victim's body was
located so okay it was his Chef
what's going on I think well Michelle
did say he was like family it's just too
bad he knew too much
so this is the thing right what's the
most likely scenario Occam's razor
Obama's Chef went for a paddleboard ride
most likely drown excuse me it's not a
cleansing if it was a Clinton Chef you'd
already find The Bullet Hole did you see
that interview
drowning they would say sorry they would
say uh uh he drowned yes they would say
he has fixated underwater yeah because
the water entered the bullet hole in his
lungs exactly if you haven't seen the
Patrick Anthony when he talks about the
Clinton Body Count Anthony Weiner goes
off the rails for like 20 minutes it's
hilarious oh Anthony Comey and I did it
once and it's like how many people
commit suicide running through the woods
yelling help and get shot in the back
it's the normal thing that happens I
don't know why you would question it but
to be fair you know so I've gone through
the Clinton Body Count thing and some of
these things are big stretches some of
them are really weird yeah some of them
are a big set I do agree there's there
was that there was that journalist in
the 90s I think it was the 90s he was
like working on the CIA and then they
said he killed himself by shooting
himself twice in the head whatever and
then people will try to explain it away
like well sometimes you know these
horrible things happen people fail and
they try again and it's like okay sure
whatever but a lot of them are like an
accountant at an insurance firm the
clintons once used and I'm like oh come
on you're a plane crash like unrelated
they do yeah they do play a lot of uh
Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon in order to
get there in the connection a lot of
them are just like you do I think they
met once at a cocktail party but then
there are some that make no sense at all
for sure and then the question is is
this because the clintons are doing
really evil things yeah or is it is it
they are oh sorry but not in this but
but I'm saying this question in this
specific context yes like in terms of
you know the Clinton Global foundation
and the donations but the the question
is like are they just very powerful
people who are very well connected with
other very very powerful people in a
tight Circle so you hear stories about
security military prominent intelligence
those things happen all the time my my
point is is it unique to the clintons or
if you actually looked would you find
something similar with the Obamas
probably and that is not to say that the
Obama's did anything wrong or the
clintons harmed anyone I'm saying when
you're in these powerful positions of
wealth and Prestige and international
relations I mean come on you know
outside the United States and yeah like
if we're not in this like lovable
rainbow and Butterfly democracy that we
happen to live in right now uh Power
struggles and and people's lives like I
don't think life expectancy is very high
in the center of power in like communist
dictatorships or anything people
offering their friends their their
co-workers no I am gonna pull up this
one YouTube clip and just say because is
it from their ring cam it no it's from
it's not from their kitchen cam it's
from a Marvel movie are you sure yeah we
should have said ring cam
I read this story
the thing I thought of immediately was
like what's that movie where the guy uh
is like in his house and the cleaning
lady leaves and then she comes back in
because she forgot something and the guy
goes Winter Soldier and uh we have it
right here I'm not gonna play the club I
just want to show you this this is the
scene so uh what's his name Alexander
Pierce he's talking with the Winter
Soldier who's like this former Soviet
you know assassin yeah the other Obama
Chef that's right the cleaning lady
leaves and then she like forgets her
phone and she walks back in and then
pierces in there sitting there and he
goes oh Renata I wish you would have
knocked and then he just shoots her yeah
and so it's like that's the first thing
I thought of like why would the chef be
paddle boarding the Obama's house it's
like I understand you're a chef but like
we we have people who come and clean the
office they don't hang out in our
backyard and go skating and like if you
found them in our you know deer blind or
whatever it'd be weird it's like a level
of comfort you're not expecting I will
say there are some private chefs
especially with these like more remote
private States you know that'll come
spend the week there and they they have
a place that they stay and maybe he just
had like yeah he lives there is my guess
yeah but it is weird but we have seen
the Rapids of a pond yeah there's
another person allegedly with him is
that confirmed or denied also were the
Obamas there at the time that's kind of
what I want to know I wonder how big the
pond is well so it's hot there's a heat
wave could have been drinking or like if
you just fell off and hit your head and
like that does happen you know what I
mean like someone called 9-1-1
apparently they called it in so someone
knew he was under the water who was it
so is this I mean maybe he was drowning
and they're like help help that's very
possible yeah I feel like there'd be
more that we would know
I I just hope everyone's okay yeah
everywhere I hope everyone's okay it
does seem like they're not like we're
not getting all the details right yeah
it feels like something's being hidden
and I think it's always because it's an
ex-president and I I think it's weird
that we haven't gotten any like because
we haven't gotten a the Obamas we're not
there at the time that makes me assume
they were on the estate which like might
explain why their personal chef was
there but also I don't know I just I
feel like there's something off the
post-millennial has this they say in the
past Campbell's his name uh wrote the
words still can't swim in a hashtag on
Instagram
so then why was he paddle boarding on
eight feet of water huh is that is that
that's what it was I mean I mean they're
not very big as a foot and a half off
what is a pond they're muddy at the
bottom so if you hit the bottom his feet
might have got tangled that's true it's
like quicksand well like I'm saying
Mario if he like lost balance and
there's one rock there and he hits his
head and then it's that he's unconscious
and then he turned like that sounds
awful but the reality is occasionally
these things happen no they do no foul
play so what what defines what a pond is
it says uh the technical distinction
between the pond and the lake has not
been universally standardized blah blah
blah some region the US to find Pond as
a body of water with a surface area of
less than 10 acres you know what I can
just pull up satellite images of
Martha's Vineyard yeah like if I was
there with the dude and he fell off his
paddle board I would immediately go in
the water after the guy yeah
blazingly hammered or something like
that more like you go in and even if
you're conscious when you get them out
you still have to call 9-1-1 I feel like
in my drinking days I would have gone in
for sure like that wouldn't have
prevented it at all it may not have
helped that would have been more heroic
it would have been like I got this guys
I'm a swimmer one arm yeah and then
someone would have came in and got us
both so I only have a general idea of
where the Obama's uh house is it's
Martha's Vineyard but yeah but there is
an area that's called a pond I'm not
gonna I don't want to pull it up because
I don't wanna everybody knows where his
house is you can Google it but I'm you
know but there is a pond it's pretty big
it's pretty big you know I don't know
how deep it is but it looks like
decently large enough to go paddle board
on and you know so I don't know I
suppose everybody there's gonna be a lot
of people who would prefer it to be some
kind of uh deeper conspiracy but the sad
reality is it's probably not some dude
who couldn't swim probably just fell off
his paddle board I just probably had a
couple
uh yeah saying he was found at a depth
eight feet and about a hundred feet from
the edge of the shore of the area yeah
that's not good so that seems he
probably didn't get out very far and
realize paddleboard sucks
I was like I'm gonna go back
slipped tafari Campbell he was a sous
chef at the White House during the Obama
Administration and stayed on with the
family when they moved to a private life
so I guess a question like did he live
with them probably if he stayed with him
for that long yeah he's probably lived
at the house and I think that's not
crazy depending on like how big and how
wealth you are like housekeepers
sometimes live and like most people's
houses yeah mine does eight feet oh yeah
that's crazy could you imagine like
being I have one of their bodies just
two feet of water above you and you're
like there is air and you can't get to
it no yeah especially like how tall is
this guy right like if he's over six
feet that's just two feet like yeah for
me I'd be like it's pretty far but for
him that's a distance you know what I
don't understand I don't understand not
being able to swim
yeah well I understand some people can't
I'm just saying you grew up with a pool
or access to one that's how he got his
name sometimes I mean
you know how to swim but uh we didn't we
didn't swim
ever I mean did you get what I don't
mean is how to just go like this though
to get up to the surface like I feel
like dogs do that I gotta learn to cup
your fingers that's the biggest part
yeah you know so what I was told when I
was little sideways when I was younger
because I asked like how do people not
know how to swim it's because they Panic
yeah they just start hitting the water
instead of actually yeah it's hilarious
there was that um actress is it naira
Vera she was in Glee and she drowned one
or two years ago at this point and part
of the story was like it's not that
drownings happened so often there but
she was getting her son out of the water
and they think just in that circumstance
it's not that she couldn't swim but like
the Panic of trying to get her child out
and whatever was happening oh that's
right isn't it like the ocean or
something I think it was in California
on a lake
nose and Kelly
um I think that's one of the weird
things about drowning people feel like
hopefully some part of your brain kicks
in and says get to the surface but if
you're really panicked you can become
kind of irrational well it's not so so
my understanding is drowning recently in
a pool though and he grew up with a pool
I mean it's an involuntary reaction when
you begin drowning you like that's what
happens is the water goes in your mouth
you try to breathe and then people's
hands go straight out and they just
Panic like not I shouldn't say Panic so
wrong that's not what I'm trying to say
it's like an inventare reaction and
people don't realize they're drowning
because they're not freaking out and
splashing like crazy they're just
sitting there at the water level I think
what it is is God created a water world
and a land world and we're invading it
yeah we kept the salt water inside of us
yeah like we should we shouldn't be in
there messing around with their habitat
you don't see whales walking around like
we take them and bring them here could
you imagine if like dolphins built land
ships we're just like driving yeah just
like looking at us we're anti-watering
watching you through a hole in the fence
I think about that a lot we're like
amoeba that have created this like
sealant around our salt water we just
carry it around yeah that's freaking
wild right it is yeah so I think we
should just stay out of there it's our
fault what have we done are we
amphibious yeah we've this we've brought
it upon ourselves
you don't think it's Obama you think
this this man who drowned Knew Too Much
about the water he saw something there
they saw him and they were like what are
you doing the murder people in the pond
were like get it get it they were like
look I've made it clear yeah you don't
know what's living in there the Naga we
don't know what he took from the White
House like you could take one thing and
he took like a monster that lives in
ponds thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time